okay as I t's to you earlier this week
Donald Trump has fired another cabinet
member the Secretary of the VA Veterans
Affairs David Shulkin we saw this coming
the chaos the turnover and Trump staff
and in the cabinet it's off the charts
it is actually historic quite literally
and the reported reasons for this firing
are that Shulkin in part wasn't moving
quickly enough to privatize the VA which
by the way would be an absolute and
total disaster it's good that Shulkin
was resisting the privatization of the
VA and also an inappropriate travel
expenditure was listed which seems to be
a problem kind of of epidemic
proportions in Trump's cabinet Shulkin
is denying that this is a problematic
use of federal funds of taxpayer money
for travel I guess there was the idea
that it was some kind of
all-expenses-paid European vacation
forum he says now it was not an
appropriate travel but that's not the
most ridiculous part right the most
ridiculous part of all of this is that
the replacement to Shulkin as VA
secretary is gonna be that doctor who
flattered Trump about how healthy he was
on national television dr. Ronnie
Jackson is Donald Trump's preferred
replacement to be secretary of the VA
Trump tweeting about this I am pleased
to announce that I intend to nominate
highly respected Admiral Ronnie al
Jackson MD as the Secretary of Veterans
Affairs in the interim the Honorable
Robert Wilkie of the DoD will serve as
Acting Secretary I'm thankful for dr.
David shulk in service to our country
and to our great veterans this is the
guy who said that Donald Trump weighs
239 pounds and is 6 feet 3 inches tall
Jackson has no experience as an
administrator of a major department the
VA is actually one of the biggest
departments or agencies that any cabinet
secretary oversees but he did say nice
things about Trump publicly which I
guess now gets you a job and Trump and
Republicans have been
on the VA is a disaster under Obama
we've got to fix it we've got to take
care of our veterans it's in shambles
this is a paramount importance it's just
horrible terrible and despicable and
then you bring in Ronnie Jackson to fix
the problems of the massive Department
of Veterans Affairs and there is one
possible glimmer of hope here
I'm skeptical about this I actually
don't think this is likely to happen but
in order to get the job dr. Ronnie
Jackson is going to have to testify
under oath right there's going to be a
confirmation hearing for dr. Ronnie
Jackson that is an opportunity for him
to be asked about that infamous glowing
review of Donald Trump's health and I
would presume that I'm the unlikely
event that he's even asked about it he
would probably say something like Oh
HIPAA laws preclude me from answering
those questions even though the results
were already made public that's an
absolutely ridiculous assertion I would
love to see him questioned about how he
came up with just the amazing health
report of clearly obese clearly not six
three clearly not 239 pound Donald Trump
bottom line nepotism cronyism the
calling card of this administration
really I think that that's the bottom
line that we're sort of getting to and
it's not it's cartoonish that this is
who's going to be potentially running
the department of the VA but it's not
really surprising we've become
accustomed to it because of how the
hiring process works either you go on
Fox or friends or you make sure in one
way or another to go on national
television yeah praise huh yeah I praise
Trump um I don't think it's a surprise
at all I am reading that this may not be
a shoo-in that dr. Ronnie Jackson
actually may have real problems going
through the confirmation process and
it's one of these situations where I
wanted to make sure to cover the story
today because this could completely blow
up in his face once it becomes clear
that the guy has no experience and is
completely out of his league to be doing
this and we may not even see him get to
confirmation hearings as we've seen
happen before where people say you know
what this my nomination has become a
distraction yeah I'm gonna remove myself
from the running if he rescinds the
nomination I think I can be up for it
all I do is say that Trump is six-five
190 pounds yeah you'll be you'll be
shoot Trump will try to appoint you by
executive order and skip confirmation
hearings altogether if you can give him
6 5 and 220 that I think he would love
that absolutely send me your thoughts
about this it's being discussed on our
subreddit at david pakman.com slash our
IDI di t today's program made possible
in part by wink if I were given the task
of picking out a wine that I was going
to like with the catch that it couldn't
be a bottle of wine that I had tried
before I wouldn't know where to start
because I'm clueless about wine that's
where wink comes in spell the winc wink
makes it easy to discover great wines
every month they ship you wines that
have been matched to your taste and
personalized to you through what they
call their palate profile quiz so you
can go to try wink comm slash Pakman and
again that's WI and see you'll get asked
just a few simple questions how do you
like your coffee
do you like raspberries or blueberries
and a few other questions and using
those answers the wink system will match
you to great wines you haven't tried
before personalized to you and delivered
right to your door as you drink more
wines and rate them yes or no yay or nay
I like or don't like
wink will learn and continue to send you
new personalized delicious wines for the
next month no membership fees you can
skip any delivery that you want cancel
anytime and wink has a 100% satisfaction
guarantee so you'll never have to pay
for a bottle you don't like and for a
limited time our viewers and listeners
can get $20 off when you go to try wink
comm slash Pakman that's tri wink
spelled T ry winc comm /p a que ma n for
$20 off that's tri wink comm slash
Pakman